What's up everyone! Knuckles cracked,
G-Fuel shaked  *glug glug glug glug glug*
That's right, it's gaming time
Walking Dead episode 4
*clap clap*
I can't believe we're here
we've finally
we're here *laughs*
it's happening
Big props to -
I don't know exactly who's involved
to help make sure this project got finished
But I really respect the people for pulling through
𝘶𝘩
Despite the company
declaring bankruptcy
& all that jazz 🎷
I'm kinda playing this..
I know people are gonna be mad
at me, just sayin' it
I just wanna see the ending, basically
It's like watching one of those TV shows
where it's like 𝘢𝘦𝘩
guess I'll watch the last episodes
That's how I see thi-
*cut to recap*
Maybe we'll get super into it
who knows?
I don't know
Maybe it's a great ending
⚠️I'm just cautiously optimistic⚠️
Yeah, we know you know that
ᵤₕ 𝓌ₑₗₗ . .... ₖᵢₗₗᵢₙ𝓰 ...
You need to stop doing that, AJ
it's not good for you
uHOH whaT?
excuse me AJ? (⬜↑)
Oh yeah, he just went for the shot didn't he
ʰᵐ
interesting
very interesting
I wonder what it's like to grow up in a world
that so many bad things are just normal
That it's sort of
-cause that you have other people
with their definition of bad & good
but you've grown up in this..
nature that
is obviously so much different